now last night I told you that I thought
the White House made a rather
unfortunate decision giving ABC anchor
George Stephanopoulos two days worth of
access to President Trump after
traveling on Air Force One to Iowa
the former Bill Clinton comms director
chilled with the president in the Oval
Office where he found his only possible
vertical inch advantage over the
commander-in-chief the foreigners if
Russia if China if someone else offers
you information on opponent should they
accept it or should they call the FBI I
think maybe you do both I think you
might want to listen I don't there's
nothing wrong with listening if I
thought there was something wrong I'd go
maybe to the FBI if I thought there was
something wrong now of course Trump's
off-the-cuff response which seemed to me
more like a kind of a flick off sent the
Democrats and their press poodles into
the stratosphere it disintegrates at the
very core of what our democracy is about
we have a president in the United States
who's not playing on America's Team
confessing his his immorality his
corruption his his sluggishness
accepting assistance from a hostile
foreign power like Russia his treasonous
behavior foreign interference treasonous
democracy imperiled oh my oh my good
Susan Rice that was a great one seeing
her pop up in that montage now
apparently we're to believe that
President Trump said what he said in
order to what invite on camera foreign
governments to help him win reelection
again all in plain sight now I'm not
saying that the president shouldn't have
maybe handle the question slightly
differently maybe should have but let's
not be foolish over the Democrats
supposed concern now about foreign
interference in America's business now
first off it was Hillary Clinton's
campaign itself that paid for that phony
Russian dossier hawked by former British
mi6 officer Christopher Steele now this
was all filtered through the sleazy Oppo
research firm which
fusion GPS run by the ever Shady Glen
Simpson now you all have real lives I
know so you may have forgotten that
Nellie or the wife of do Jays Bruce or
worked at fusion and met with Trump
dossier author and former British spy
Christopher Steele the day before the
FBI launched is Trump Russia
investigation so where was lets say
congressman Adler's outrage about any of
this I don't know what that means and it
may just be public relations I don't
know that's what I was wondering
Hannah why no Nancy Pelosi press
conference demanding to know what Obama
officials knew and when they knew it
I don't know what that is what are you
referencing well this was Russia making
salacious claims about an American
presidential candidate and the heat of a
very contentious campaign now I would
argue that Donald Trump has always been
very open about his desire to play
hardball politics to win you saw that on
camera but the Clinton team was always
in concealment mode they were aided and
abetted by an Obama DOJ and deep State
that was desperate to see to it that
Trump was defeated and then after he won
that he was removed from office so all
the feigned outrage from Democrats over
foreign interference it also made me
think of something else when was the
last time you heard Democrats complain
about what the Chinese have been up to
here in America as the u.s. scrambles to
learn the extent of a massive theft of
federal government personnel records
said to have been stolen by China NBC
News has obtained a classified
government report that shows the
remarkably pervasive reach of Chinese
cyber spying nationwide this National
Security Agency map shows a red dot for
every successful computer intrusion by
China over the past five years nearly
700 with computer attacks in every state
I mean that report went on and on now
does that look a little more pervasive
than all the claims of
Russian interference and meddling from
some Facebook hackers and in basements
in Russia you bet it does and that
report doesn't even address massive
efforts by the Chinese to steal are very
sensitive intellectual property or
infiltrate America's premier research
universities the Democrats demand
retaliation or hold endless hearings
after China stole all those personnel
files from the Office of Personnel
Management this all shows us that the
Democrats aren't really worried about
foreign countries meddling in our
affairs they just saw this yesterday as
a convenient way to resurrect the
moribund Mellor Muller investigation and
maybe even push their leadership to take
up impeachment hearings once and for all
and maybe in an odd way this kind of
ill-advised interview with
Stephanopoulos will end up forcing the
Democrats into the corner that Nancy
Pelosi hoped to avoid wasting the
nation's time with needless politically
motivated impeachment hearings during an
election year and that's the angle